58 years of girls glamour and glitz have
made Hugh Hefner the ultimate Playboy
three decades after his London playboy
club closed its doors he feels the time
is right to bring the pony girl back to
the UK and he's brought along his 25
year old fiance for the launch the
return of the bunnies has a retro chic
quality about it you know it's it's a
you know back to back to the 60s you
know James Bond the Beatles and the
bunnies the world has has gone through
many permutations but you know there was
a fascination with that that that more
sophisticated more romantic time that
the people Miss Hughes worth 26 million
pounds but he says his adult
entertainment Empire symbolizes much
more than a thriving business properly
understood Playboy and for the end of
sexism there was the truth no matter the
real sexist era came before Playboy and
playboy played a very real part in
changing all of that women were being
held in bondage for hundreds of years in
the owned by first their fathers and
then by their husbands as if playboy
helped to change all that for the sexual
revolution was all about while Hefner
promotes Playboy's contribution to
society his new club has angered
protesters who say it's far from
liberating women see that playboy are
about the exploitation of women they're
about the degradation of women and I
think they're rightly angry of the way
that playboy is trying to legitimize
pornography trying to bring it into the
mainstream and this club is another step
in that direction the feminist protest
at 2011 to the Playboy Bunnies is lame
because I mean look around you certainly
things of a sexual nature are everywhere
now and you know playboy has more of a
romantic connection I mean page three is
sexier in the bunnies it's not the first
time he's come up against his critics
and probably won't be the last but with
lifetime membership cost
fifteen thousand pounds the number of
people exposed to the bunnies will be
kept to a minimum Jane with a spoon Sky
News